sẵn rau dịch tương mừng sáo đến mười tháng người, khi chúng chúng hóan Việt Nam vinh nhận đã bước phá mạnh mẽ,
sau sự kiện tổ chức xế phảng APTS A'RUSSEL chính thức nâng hạn Việt Nam lên nhỏ mọi người thử cấp.
Chỉ số về nợi đách kết thúc tòan ở móc mỗi ít vệ trăm 4 miệ bẩy về nằm me làm điểm,
tăng hơn 1 chăm điểm sau về tuần trước.
Thành khoản biển quân đặt khoảng 30 lâm ít thì đồng vội phían cho thử dòng tiền tiếp tục đổ mạnh và các cộp phéo chủ củ.
Sông sòng với thông tin lưng hàng ngày mời tháng mời sở gió dịch chức khoản thành vổ hộ chỉ mình tổ chức hai chương hợp đồng tương lai về lợm mù trăm.
Sản phẩm mới này không chỉ mở dộ công cụ đầu tư và phòng gử dụi gió mà còn có phần gia tăng chờ sâu trước thị trường phải xin.
Để là bức đi tiếp theo trong lỗi lực phát triển thị trường vốn độu vộ và bệnh vấn.
Các chuyển ra nhận định, lếu sòng vốn suy trị ord định và lan thoà sang nhóm ngừng hàng, bất động sản, thép và đầu tư công,
thị trường có thể sắc lập định cao mở trong thời gian tới.